I've been living in Los Angeles for two
years and I've never been this cold in
my life I will pay anyone here $300 for
gore-tex gloves anybody I'm serious I
have the cash
before I begin I must point out that
behind me sits a highly admired
President of the United States and
decorated war hero while I a cable
television talk show host has been
chosen to stand here and in part wisdom
I pray I never witnessed a more damning
example of what is wrong with America
today
graduates faculty parents relatives
undergraduates and old people that just
come to these things good morning and
congratulations to the Dartmouth class
of 2011
today you have achieved something
special something only 92% of Americans
your age will ever know a college
diploma that's right with your college
diploma you now have a crushing
advantage over 8% of the workforce
I'm talking about dropout losers like
Bill Gates Steve Jobs and Mark
Zuckerberg incidentally speaking of mr.
Zuckerberg only at Harvard would someone
have to invent a massive social network
just to talk with someone in the next
room my first job as your commencement
speaker is to illustrate that life is
not fair for example you have worked
tirelessly for four years to earn the
Diploma you'll be receiving this weekend
that was great and Dartmouth is giving
me the same degree for interviewing the
fourth lead in Twilight deal with it
another example that life is not fair if
it does rain the powerful rich people on
stage get the tent
deal with it I would like to thank
President Kim for inviting me here today
after my phone call with President Kim I
decided to find out a little bit about
the man he goes by President Kim and
doctor Kim to his friends he's Jim Kim J
to the K special k JK rowling the just
kidding Kim ster and most puzzling
stinky Pete he serves as the chair of
the department of global health and
social medicine at Harvard Medical
School spearheaded a task force for the
World Health Organization on global
health initiatives won a MacArthur
Genius grant and was one of Time
Magazine's 100 most influential people
in 2006 good god man what the hell are
you compensating for
seriously we get it you're smart by the
way dr. Jim you were brought to
Dartmouth to lead and is the world-class
anthropologist you were also hired to
figure out why each of these graduating
students ran around a bonfire 111 times
but I thank you for inviting me here
stinky Pete and it is an honor though
some of you may see me as a celebrity
you should know that I once sat where
you sit
literally late last night I snuck out
here and sat in every seat I did it to
prove a point I'm not bright and I have
a lot of free time but this is a
wonderful occasion it's great to be here
in New Hampshire where I am getting an
honorary degree and all the legal
fireworks I can fit in the trunk of my
car you know New Hampshire is such a
special place when I arrived I took a
deep breath of this crisp New England
air and thought wow I'm in this state
that's next to the state where Ben and
Jerry's ice cream is made but don't get
me wrong I take my class today very
seriously when I got the call two months
ago to be your speaker I decided to
prepare with the same intensity many of
you have devoted to an important term
paper so late last night I began
I drank two cans of Red Bull snorted
some adderall played a few hours of Call
of Duty and then open my browser I think
Wikipedia put it best when they said
Dartmouth College is a private Ivy
League university in Hanover New
Hampshire United States thank you and
good luck to communicate with you
students today I have gone to great
lengths to become well-versed in your
unique linguistic patterns in fact just
this morning I left Baker berry with my
trippy berry to eat a Billy Bob at the
Bema when my Flixter Francesca was
blitzed jacked by some d-bag on his MSP
yes I've done my research this College
was named after the second Earl of
Dartmouth a good friend of the third
Earl of UC Santa Cruz and the Duke of
the Barbizon School of Beauty your
school motto is Fox clematis and deserto
which means voice crying out in the
wilderness this is easily the most
pathetic school motto I have ever heard
[Applause]
apparently it narrowly beat out silently
weeping in thick shrub and whimpering in
voice leave without pants
sure school color is green and this
color was chosen by Frederick Mather in
1867 because and this is true I looked
it up quote it was the only color that
had not been taken already
I cannot remember hearing anything so
sad Dartmouth you have an inferiority
complex and you should not you have
graduated more great fictitious
Americans than any other college
Meredith Grey of Grey's Anatomy Pete
Campbell from Mad Men Michael Corleone
from The Godfather
in fact I look forward to next year's
valedictory address by our esteemed
classmate Count Chocula of course your
greatest fictitious graduate is Treasury
Secretary Timothy Geithner man can you
imagine if a real Treasury secretary
made those kinds of decisions
[Laughter]
now I know what you're gonna say
Dartmouth you're gonna say well we've
got dr. Seuss well guess what we're all
tired of hearing about dr. Seuss face it
the man rhymed
falou soul with sass noozle in the
literary community that's called
cheating your insecurity is so great
Dartmouth that you don't even think you
deserve a real podium I'm sorry what the
hell is this thing it looks like you
stole it from the set of survivor Nova
Scotia seriously it looks like something
a bear would use at an AAA meeting no
Dartmouth you must stand tall raise your
heads high and feel proud because if
Harvard Yale and Princeton are your
self-involved vain name-dropping older
brothers you were the cool sexually
confident lacrosse playing younger
sibling who knows how to throw a party
and looks good in a Down Vest
Brown of course is your lesbian sister
who never leaves her room and pen
Columbia and Cornell well frankly who
gives a [ __ ]
[Applause]
yes I've always had a special bond with
this tool in fact this is my second time
coming here when I was 17 years old and
touring colleges way back in the fall of
1980 I came to Dartmouth Dartmouth was a
very different place back then I made
the trip up from Boston on a mule after
asking the blacksmith in West lab for
directions I came to this beautiful
campus
no dormitories had been built yet so I
stayed with a family of fur traders in
White River Junction it snowed heavily
during my visit and I was trapped here
for four months I was forced to eat the
mule who a week earlier had been forced
to eat the fur traders still I love
Dartmouth and I vowed to return but fate
dealt a heavy blow with no money I was
forced to enroll in a small local
commuter school a pulsating sore on a
muddy elbow of the Charles River that
was a miserable wretch and did this say
I cannot help but wonder what if I had
gone to Dartmouth if I had gone to
Dartmouth I might have spent at least
some of my college years outside and
today I might not be allergic to all
plant life as well as most types of rock
if I had gone to Dartmouth right now I'd
be wearing a fleece thong instead of a
lace thong
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if I had gone to Dartmouth I still
wouldn't know the second verse to dear
old Dartmouth face it none of you do you
all mumble that part if I had gone to
Dartmouth I'd have a liver the size and
consistency of a beanbag chair finally
if I had gone to Dartmouth today I'd be
getting an honorary degree at Harvard
imagine how awesome that would be
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you are a great school and you deserve a
historic commencement address that's
right I want my message today to be
forever remembered because it changed
the world to do this I must suggest
ground baked breaking policy Winston
Churchill gave his famous iron curtain
speech at Westminster College in 1946
JFK outlined his nuclear disarmament
policy at American University in 1963
today I would like to set forth my own
policy here at Dartmouth I call it the
coning doctrine under the coning
doctrine all bachelor degrees will be
upgraded to master's degrees all
master's degrees will be upgraded to
PhDs and all MBA students will be
immediately transferred to a white color
prison
under the Cohen doctrine Winter Carnival
will become winter carnival and be moved
to Rio clothing will be optional all
expenses paid by the Alumni Association
your nickname the big green will be
changed to something more kick-ass like
the Jade blade the seafoam Avenger
or simply lime Zilla the deep plan and
quarter system will finally be updated
to the 164th system semesters will last
three days students will be encouraged
to take 48 semesters off they must
however be on campus during their
sophomore fourth of July under the Conan
doctrine
I will reinstate tube stock and I will
punish those who try to replace it with
field stock rafting and beer are a much
better combination than a field and a
beer I happen to know that in two years
they were going to downgrade heeled
stock to desk stock 7 hours of fun
sitting quietly at your desk don't let
those bastards do it and finally under
the Cohen doctrine all commencement
speakers who shamelessly pander with
cheap insight references designed to get
childish applause will be forced to
apologize to the greatest graduating
class in the history of the world
Dartmouth class of 2011 rolls
besides policy another hallmark of great
commencement speeches is deep profound
advice like reach for the stars well
today I'm not gonna waste your time with
empty cliches instead I'm gonna give you
real practical advice that you will need
to know if you're going to survive the
next few years first adult acne lasts
longer than you think I almost canceled
two days ago because I had a zit on my
eye guys this is important you cannot
iron his shirt while wearing it there's
another one if you live on ramen noodles
for too long you lose all feelings in
your hands and your stool becomes a
white gel and finally wearing colorful
converse high tops beneath your
graduation robe is a great way to tell
your classmates this is just the first
of many horrible decisions you plan to
make with the rest of your life of
course there many parents here and I
have real advice for them as well
parents you should write this down many
of your children you haven't seen them
in four years
well now you're about to see them every
day when they come out of the basement
to tell you the Wi-Fi isn't working if
your child majored in fine arts or
philosophy you have a good reason to be
worried the only place they are now
really qualified to get a job is ancient
Greece good luck with that degree the
traffic today on East we lop is gonna be
murder so once they start handing out
diplomas you should slip out in the
middle of the case and I have to tell
you this you will spend more money
framing your child's diploma then they
will earn in the next six months it's
tough out there so be patient
the only people hiring right now are
Panera Bread and Mexican drug cartels
yes you parents must be patient because
it is indeed a grim job market out there
one of the reasons it's so tough finding
work is that aging baby boomers refuse
to leave their jobs trust me on this
even when they promise you for five
years they're going to leave and say it
on television I mean you can go on
YouTube right now and watch the guy do
it there is no guarantee they won't come
back
of course I'm speaking generally but
enough this is not a time for grim
prognostications or negativity no I came
here today because believe it or not I
actually do have something real to tell
you eleven years ago I gave an address
to a graduating class at Harvard I have
not spoken at a graduation since because
I thought I had nothing left to say but
then 2010 came and Allen here a 3,000
miles from my home because I learned a
hard but profound lesson last year not
to share it with you in 2000 I told
graduates don't be afraid to fail well
now I'm here to tell you that they you
should not fear failure you should do
your very best to avoid it
Nietzsche famously said whatever doesn't
kill you makes you stronger
what he failed to stress is that it
almost kills you
disappointment stings and for driven
successful people like yourselves it is
disorienting what Nietzsche should have
said is whatever doesn't kill you makes
you watch a lot of Cartoon Network and
drink mid-price Chardonnay at 11:00 in
the morning now by definition
commencement speakers at an Ivy League
college are considered successful but a
little over a year ago I experienced a
profound and very public disappointment
I did not get what I wanted and I left a
system that had nurtured and helped
define me for the better part of 17
years I went from being in the center of
the grid to nominally off the grid but
underneath the coffee table that the
grid sits on lost in the shag carpeting
that is underneath the coffee table
supporting the grid it was the making of
a career disaster and a terrible analogy
but then something spectacular happened
fog-bound with no compass and adrift I
started trying things I grew a strange
cinnamon beard I'd over the world of
social media
I started tweeting my comedy I threw
together a national tour I played the
guitar I did stand-up were a skin-tight
blue leather suit recording an album
made a documentary and frightened my
friends and family ultimately I
abandoned all preconceived perceptions
of my career path and stature and took a
job on basic cable with a network most
famous for showing reruns along with
sitcoms created by a tall black man who
dresses like an old black woman I did a
lot of silly unconventional spontaneous
and seemingly irrational things and
guess what with the exception of the
blue leather suit
it was the most satisfying and
fascinating year of my professional life
to this day I still don't understand
exactly what happened but I have never
had more fun but more challenged and
this is important had more conviction
about what I was doing how could this be
true well it's simple
there are a few things more liberating
in this life than having your worst fear
realized I went to college with many
people who prided themselves on knowing
exactly who they were and exactly where
they were going at Harvard five
different guys in my class told me they
would one day be President of the United
States four of them were later killed in
motel shootouts the other ones briefly
hosted Blue's Clues before dying
senselessly and yet another motel
shootout your path at 22 will not
necessarily be your path at 32 or 42
one's dream is constantly evolving
rising and falling changing course this
happens in every job but because I have
worked in comedy for 25 years I can
probably speak best about my own
profession way back in the 1940s there
was a very very funny man named Jack
Benny he was a giant star easily one of
the greatest comedians of his generation
and a much younger man named Johnny
Carson wanted very much to be Jack Benny
in some way he's in some ways he was but
in many ways he wasn't he emulated Jack
Benny but his own quirks and mannerisms
along with the changing medium pulled
him in a different direction and yet his
failure to completely become his hero
made him the funniest person of his
generation David Letterman wanted to be
Johnny Carson and was not and as a
result my generation of comedians wanted
to be David Letterman and none of us are
my peers and I have all missed that mark
in a thousand different ways but the
point is this it is our failure to
become our perceived ideal that
ultimately defines us and makes us
unique it's not easy but if you accept
your misfortune and handle it right your
perceived failure can become a catalyst
for profound reinvention so
at the age of 47
so at the age of 47 after 25 years of
obsessively pursuing my dream that dream
changed for decades and showbusiness the
ultimate goal of every comedian was to
host the Tonight Show it was the Holy
Grail and like many people I thought
that achieving that goal would define me
as successful but that is not true no
specific job or career goal defines me
and it should not define you in 2000 in
2000 I told graduates to not be afraid
to fail and I still believe that but
today I tell you that whether you fear
it or not disappointment will come the
beauty is that through disappointment
you can gain clarity and with clarity
comes conviction and true originality
many of you here today are getting your
diploma at this Ivy League school
because you have committed yourself to a
dream and worked hard to achieve it and
there is no greater cliche in a
commencement address than follow your
dream well I'm here to tell you that
whatever you think your dream is now it
will probably change and that's okay
four years ago many of you had a
specific vision of what your college
experience was going to be and who you
were going to become and I bet today
most of you would admit that your time
here was very different from what you
imagined your roommates changed your
major changed for some of you your
sexual orientation changed I bet some of
you have changed your sexual orientation
since I began this speech I know I have
but through the good and especially the
bad the person you are now is someone
you could never have conjured in the
fall of 2007 I've told you many things
today most of it foolish but some of it
true I'd like to end my address by
breaking a taboo and quoting myself from
17 months ago at the end of my final
program with NBC just before signing off
I said work hard be kind and amazing
things will happen today receiving this
honor and speaking to the Dartmouth
class of 2011
from behind a tree trunk
have never believed that more thank you
very much in congratulations